[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si nous rentrons dans une escalade nous
devrons faire face à un véritable
tsunami pour l'ensemble de la planète
pour la première fois de notre histoire
parlementaire
nous accueillons le président d'un pays
en guerre
d'un pays à la capitale a siégé
sur lesquelles les frappes redoublent
d'intensité en ce moment même soyez sûr
monsieur le président de la solidarité
et de l'entière mobilisation de la
représentation nationale que nous nous
levions et applaudissions afin de rendre
hommage au courage du peuple ukrainien
et de vous-même monsieur le président
monsieur zelensky il joue son rôle mais
moi je l'idolâtrent pas parce que je
n'oublie pas les bombardements encore la
semaine dernière y compris le 20h de tf1
on a fait un reportage par l'armée
ukrainienne de l'est du pays 26 civils
tués vous savez pourquoi cela s'est
produit et vous savez qui est coupable
il vient de prendre le contrôle de
toutes les télévisions en ukraine on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé en france de tout
cela il vient d'interdire onze partis
d'opposition dont l'un qui a
complètement condamné l'invasion russe 1
donc ce n'est pas le critère la réponse
sont importants depuis le premier jour
en étant aux côtés du peuple craignant
les dents à résister on y reviendra sans
doute avec cette limite qui est que la
france n'est pas part au conflit mais en
aidant à résister en accueillant en
sanctionnant la russie d'entreprises
françaises doivent quitter le marché
russe
rno auchan leroy merlin et les autres
doivent arrêter de sponsoriser la
machine de guerre russe total explique
qu'il peut se passer du pétrole
russe mais que ça va coûter plus cher il
a annoncé aussi qu'il ne pouvait pas se
passer du gaz russe voilà on a investi
dans des usines pour presque 13
milliards de dollars et c'est pas un
problème d'argent c'est que sais-je
usines elles vont continuer à tourner
que je m'en aille ou non les russes les
font tourner très bien et deuxièmement
me retirer ces données c'est 13
milliards à des russes parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour 0 parce
qu'aujourd'hui personne ne veut acheter
ses usines en fait les russes ont été
très clairs dès lors que vous partez on
met la main sur votre participation sur
vos sociétés en russie en les
nationalisant ni quand on sort on ne
revient pas en fait exactement donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qui est le
perdant dans l'histoire les conflits
s'emboîtent la guerre ukraine russie
s'insère dans un dans une confrontation
entre les états unis et la chine et
cette confrontation sincères elle-même
dans une confrontation entre les pays
autoritaires et les démocraties
libérales s'était pas lors d'une
conférence de presse sur le sujet
spécifiquement craignant voici ce que
dit joe biden c'est le moment où les
choses changent va y avoir un nouvel
ordre mondial jusque là oui et nous
devons le diriger du simple badge anne
hidalgo à 2 euros à la bouteille de
champagne marine le pen présidente à 30
euros en passant par les briques et
tee-shirts casquettes poncho sur
internet ou en meeting tous les goodies
il
a peur de son ombre ils n'osent pas
faire campagne et les reclus et laissez
vous êtes
vous acceptez vous êtes engagés au
service national universel l'état la
collectivité vous offre parmi vous paye
le code les heures le diplôme ça fait la
huitième fois qu'un le pen se présente
aux élections aux élections nationales
si les français on voulait je pense que
ce serait déjà fait mais maintenant
c'est vous les journalistes
kenzo peur plus personne n'a plus
confiance en vous non plus quant à eric
zemmour
certains ici visiblement aime beaucoup
je ne crois pas non plus qu'ils soient
en mesure de gagner donc le sujet
aujourd'hui pour eux la cgem lundi pour
le baril avait raté vous avez raté une
fois oui il faut des preuves de rieumes
et une information